so yeah I get to talk about programming
experiences and programming language
design and all these things from kind of
a different perspective than most people
um I get to talk about it as neither an
academic nor as somebody from industry
but instead as someone in a startup
doing all of this um which is kind of a
weird place to be uh for a number of
reasons for one we're on this kind of
unusual timeline when it comes to these
sorts of things um but for two we have a
very small team trying to do something
very very ambitious and if you've never
heard of Eve our goal is to uh basically
bring programming to everyone or
whatever that may mean is kind of an
interesting question um the way we've
kind of defined it is sort of in the the
original sense of the bicycle for the
mind right we think that computers
provide an incredible amount of power to
those who can control them currently
that's largely people like yourselves in
this room right it's programmers people
who have spend spent an immense amount
of time learning how to do exactly
that and so um you know being a startup
we we have the sort of Mantra of like
constantly testing things out with real
people right uh which is something that
we actually don't do very a very good
job of when it comes to our own tools in
the industry uh and as a result of that
we've actually gone through many many
many versions of Eve um so we've been
working on the project for about a year
and a half now uh during that time we've
done easily over 20 different versions
and so what I thought would be a kind of
interesting talk especially for this
group a group of people interested in
exploring this space would be to just go
through some of them and tell you about
some of the things we've learned along
the
way so let's start out the very first
version that ever existed I actually
showed at this conference two years ago
um it was called
Aurora and if you wanted to start about
you know start going about about making
a a version of programming that's better
than what we currently have um any
reasonable person would start from their
own beliefs about what better even means
right uh and in our case or in my case
um I thought you know what I really like
closure I really like immutable data I
really like functional programming I
really like sort of this repple almost
mathematica notebook style way of
working with the world let's just build
an entire platform revolving around that
can we make that workflow really really
nice can we make that fluid can we make
it efficient and what would we learn
doing so so I built this Aurora thing
and uh in this case you know you can
kind of see in the background what's
going on here I'm taking a bunch of data
and I'm performing these very closure
sequence like operations on top of it in
this particular instance I was getting
some usage data out of and
transforming it uh and you know
extracting the times out of these things
and whatnot and I go a little bit
further along and do some math which you
can see here is shown as math this is
another big thing I was really
interested in at their light table was I
want to represent domains as
themselves and then at the end you know
I want to be able to get a graph of
something really really quickly I did
all this work so I can just stick a
chart on here and drag some data to it
and Tada I get a
chart um so this was an interesting
prototype like I said if you if you were
here couple years ago you probably saw
it I went on to demonstrate hey this
works for more than that you can
actually build real applications this
way um my sort of proxy for a real
application in this point was building
to do MVC with it right something that
actually traditionally speaking doesn't
seem like it would fit a world like this
super well uh in the past two years
though we've learned that's quite the
opposite of true right react has sort of
brought a lot of this attention towards
let's do these very data Focus there's a
single data structure everything is just
a view over that data structure sort of
way of looking at the world and I kind
of built this environment um before that
kind of stuff existed but I mentioned it
isn't just about getting a version of
programming that maybe I like more right
the goal was to get more people to do it
and this was something that was an
original goal of light table um and what
we found was light table can make you
more efficient I mean big surprise being
able to like ask questions of your
software being able to execute code in
real time of course that's going to make
you faster original thought was it might
actually make programming easier but it
turned out it didn't really programming
is still hard and so you know we took
this prototype and we sort of did some
more with it we tried to make it look a
little bit better um you know we we got
rid of the weird data structur thing and
turned it into like tables right you
know um basically in a a vector of maps
is just a a table and if you have just
vectors they just represent as lists and
so on and so forth and again kept this
sort of notebook style of working and
that was that was cool we we took it
even further and like well okay you
something that you can't see it's a
little too small but you know we'll have
some code over here on the right you
have your notebook over here on the
right and you can imagine this big white
square in here is like a document that
you're building or the page that you're
building maybe you're building something
like to do MVC
again and unfortunately I couldn't find
a screenshot of the really nice version
of this so we we worked on this for a
few months um got something that I I
would have used I really liked it I
thought it was interesting and I had an
opportunity to um go to the opening of
Brett Victor's lab in San Francisco and
this was like the perfect opportunity to
test this thing out because there were a
bunch of people yeah there were
programmers there but more importantly
there were a bunch of non-programmers
there who were incredibly intelligent
right the reason why I want to give
people this superpower of of being able
to control a computer is because I want
the guys curing cancer to be able to
cure cancer faster right that's what I
want I don't want more software in the
world I want more solutions in the world
and so I needed to be able to test this
out with those kinds of folks and the
opening of a lab gave me the opportunity
to do exactly that and so I showed my
prototype and people loved the idea they
thought it was beautiful it was really
interesting and I a few of them down and
had them try and use it and amazingly
enough the usability of it was actually
kind of okay like people got around in
it they could do some some
semi-interesting things but it turned
out the model itself didn't work for
them which was not what I was expecting
functional programming didn't make a lot
of sense to them um and what it ended up
being was something I never would have
guessed the thing that we just
absolutely could not fix was scope and
of all the things we showed people all
the tests we did we could never come up
with a way to get people to get their
heads around
scoping and you think well that's not so
bad until you watch their actual
reactions right you learn so much not
statistically or any of that from from
user test you learn it from people's
reactions what they actually say to you
and what they try and do and I I will
never forget the guy who had had like
this set of nested things and he had a
value at the end of the chain and he
goes to use that up there I was like you
can't like why not I see it it's right
there I want it here you can't do that
okay well can I take this and put it
down here no right and you like try and
think about how you explain why that has
to be true and that's the important bar
why does that have to be true right um
well the programmer in you right now
might be saying well scope's important
like scope is how we have functions uh
that seems kind of important and we
found that you know dealing with lots of
data structures and nesting them is sort
of creating another version of this
exact same problem and so we realized
hey you can't really have scope you know
and you can't really have these like
deeply nested data
structures well if you don't have those
either then you don't have anything if
you don't get rid of data structures you
get rid of anything that can hold things
in order what does that even mean
anymore right like that is the
definition of programming a set of
operations an ordered set of operations
over data and I just removed all three
of those things um so I was like well
maybe that's kind of scary you know that
I don't know that that's going to work
but actually if you think about it a
little
bit there is a massively successful
example of a thing that works exactly
like that Excel is exactly this Excel
has one data structure it's a giant grid
and there's problems with that and we
can talk about that later but it has one
data structure there is no scope I can
access anything from anywhere if I see a
value I can use it right there's no
inherent ordering to it execution is not
ordered I can sit there and sort things
however I want throughout all of it um
and that is a wonderful wonderful
realization because our goal is to let
everyone do this stuff and Excel is
unquestionably the most successful
programming environment ever built even
though we don't traditionally think of
it that way it is exactly what it is um
you know hundreds upon hundreds of
millions of people people use it every
single day to do amazing things and when
we figured this out I had the
opportunity to go talk to a bunch of
them and uh I had the opportunity to
talk with somebody at a Fortune 500
company and they had this spreadsheet it
was measured in gigs in size it had been
built over a 10-year period not once had
a professional programmer ever touched
this
spreadsheet what was amazing about it
was that it modeled their entire
business a fortune 500 company inside of
a 10 plus gig
spreadsheet and the funny part was
anytime they wanted to make a change to
it they'd make a change and then go to
lunch because it took an hour and a half
for it to calls right but the important
bit here is non-programmers built an
amazing piece of software without ever
calling themselves programmers without
ever thinking of themselves as
programmers and it's a truly complex and
amazing
thing of course the problem with Excel
is it's very constrained right how would
you build say a website in Excel how
would you build a game how would you
build any number of things that just
don't naturally fit into this like
two-dimensional grid way of thinking
about the
world and so we looked again we we dug a
little bit deeper and like well is there
anything else maybe that works this way
and there is one other example that is
exactly this and that is relational
databases relational databases have no
inherent order right you can including
even in the code the execution is not
guaranteed does not have a specific
order to it um no scope you know barring
access rules I can get anything from
anywhere um and yeah there are functions
but only scalar ones right they do much
much simpler things um and that again is
a wonderful sort of realization because
if Excel is wonderfully um usable by
lots of people but constrained databases
are maybe not super usable by everyone
but amazingly flexible and Power
powerful the world runs on relational
databases um at some point every bit of
data eventually kind of touches
one so where do we go from there we did
this little thought experiment we won a
program without scope and data
structures and all these things that I
never thought we would do well there's
some very very interesting research that
you are actually going to hear about
tomorrow um the keynote speaker tomorrow
Peter Alvaro worked at the or studied at
the boom Lab at Berkeley the Berkeley
orders of magnitude lab and their stated
mandate was to make programming orders
of magnitude smaller orders of magnitude
simpler or is a magnitude faster right
all of these lovely qualities and they
did so by taking a 40 years dead
language called datal log we just heard
about prologue datalog is like prolog's
little cousin um specifically designed
for data bases and they added time to it
and found hey we can build distributed
systems this way and it's really
compelling
and I'll let him tell you more about
that and I'll tell you a little bit
about what we did with it so one of the
problems with prologue is it's predicate
logic and that's hard to understand but
we had this
intuition and this intuition was that if
you think about predicates as kind of
fill-in the blank sentences and if you
think about horn Clauses as when you see
this I want you to do this kind of
backwards from how horn Clauses normally
are um you get something that feels a
little bit like a mix between codo and
like I don't know pattern matching
unification kind of stuff right um and I
mentioned I was going to show you some
stuff so let's actually take a look at
this prototype that I built and this
interesting enough is the Prototype we
eventually raised money
on um this is a fairly early version of
it but as I was saying
um it is a system where you have these
these when you see this do this kind of
rules going on make it a a little bit
smaller here or not um when you see this
do this and what's interesting about
that one of the realizations we had is
it kind of ends up reading like a
specification a bit like when you're
setting defaults remember that the
counter is zero when you have a counter
is some value draw it as a button with
these you know with this information in
that and when the increment is clicked
you know change the counter is some
value to the counter is some Value Plus
One and this creates
a lovely button that is very powerful
and useful it can count numbers um now
as a fun side note here uh one of one of
my colleagues and I did a talk where we
went and um before we did it we had a
bunch of programmers professional
programmers try and write that program a
button on the screen that just simply
counts the number of times it was
clicked my math uh sorry my my Oxford
and Cambridge trained mathematician and
computer scientist colleague took 30
minutes to write that program and that
is not because he is a poor programmer
he's brilliant right it is because there
is so much that goes into just writing
something even that
simple uh and the idea here was well if
we have this wonderful platform or this
wonderful way of thinking about the
world you know when you do this you see
this and and it's just kind of like this
database married into a language um you
can get rid of a lot of the
complexity and so we built to do NVC of
course um unfortunately it renders funny
in a very small screen here um but you
know hey we we built it actually this
turns out to be really fast um when you
build a a language who where every
operation ends up being sort of just an
operation on a b tree because
technically speaking all this is is a
database all we're ever doing is
querying for information and sticking
new tupal in the database and that's it
um turns out when you when you have that
you can actually make it pretty darn
fast it's very memory efficient and
lotss of good things start to happen but
again we have this Mad Lib kind of way
of working right this fill-in-the blank
sentences thing and you can see here you
get you get lovely lines like when
filter active is clicked change the
filter or change filter the to-dos by
you know whatever it currently is to
filter the to-dos by active again you're
sort of just describing this this sort
of um I guess when you see this do this
sort of declarative
flow and interestingly enough this was
actually bootstrapped um it was written
in a closure script DSL this actually
all runs in the
browser uh and so that's why some of
these some of these are blank because we
didn't actually have Madlibs when we
were writing it right it's in this
DSL um here's the interesting part much
like the bloom guys uh who found that
they were able to read rewrite Hadoop in
a style like this um in thousands of
lines of code instead of 2.7 million
lines of code um I wrote the IDE all of
this stuff and about 600 lines in a week
in a language that had bugs and didn't
even have aggregation in it yet right it
was an amazing result for me I mean as
someone who knows exactly what goes into
building these sorts of things um it was
impressively small it really was orders
of magnitude
better that being said the we found some
interesting aspects to it one was turned
out that that like specification way of
thinking about the world where you were
again sort of looking at almost
instructions to the computer wasn't
really all that much better than
programming as it normally is um you
know it's like one of those we like to
talk about all these like holy grail
problems we've sort of started to nip
away out a little bit as we've G gone on
this program or on this project rather
and of course executable specifications
is one of those and I actually don't
believe in them as much anymore as I
used to the notion that um you were
going to write some sort of English
specification and and have it work I
think we could do that I actually think
if with a little bit more work this
would look a lot like it um but the
problem is if you think about English
think about the English paragraphs that
would describe Tod do MVC or whatever
you can actually get it there's an
English specification for it every
single line relies on knowledge about
the previous lines every single line is
mired in context which is the exact
problem we have with programming to
begin with is we're trying to figure
fure out where things fit in this like
massive system right and if we are
forced to constantly sort of have the
whole thing in our head before we can
understand any one bit of it then we
actually haven't gotten anything and
when we tested this out with people
that's basically exactly what we found
they could read the program they thought
it was cool they understood what they
read um but it wasn't actually didn't
actually help them program anymore um
and it didn't actually give them a sense
of sort of how the whole system worked
until until they got to the very end of
the every single one of the rules right
um and so that was kind of one of the
interesting bits of learning we got out
of that
one uh but in any case this was very
compelling we had proven that hey uh you
know the guys at Berkeley had shown you
can build distributed systems with a
data log like language we just showed
you can build websites with it we just
showed you could build an IDE with it
right and that's a very different way of
thinking about the world and a very
different set of
results so um we wanted to explore other
ways of working with it and this video
we'll be a little hard to see the
details aren't important I'll explain
kind of what's going on here in a second
um but one of the things we we knew we
liked right I had mentioned Excel and
Excel is again widely used can we make
it look like Excel if you think about
the sort of operations you do in SQL
things like joins and unions and
filtering and all that they all have
pretty natural visual mappings to
operations on a table
right if you took you think about join
you're literally taking two columns and
sticking them on top of each other Union
is taking two tables and glomming them
onto each other filtering is you know
just clicking at the top of a column and
saying I only want you know values
greater than five or whatever and so we
explored this idea of hey let's just
represent everything as a table and see
what
happens and so this was one of the first
times we got Eve to do something to the
outside world this is the first time um
we had Eve send us a text message
so the way we did this was like I said
don't don't worry too much about what's
going on here but there's a set of
tables over here on the left with a set
of columns inside of them and we're
dragging columns out onto the onto the
surface here and kind of renaming them
and I didn't describe it but the way we
think about sort of events and
interaction and the outside world is
just as again information stuck inside
of a table right so when you get a click
you do not get a click event all we do
is stick a tube inside of a clicks table
or whatever um and uh then you write
views over top of that table so if I
want to you know write the increment or
button what I do is count the number of
Clicks in the click table right um and
that's kind of what's going on here is
to we you know I have a set of buttons
down there at the bottom that have our
names on them and I click on them and we
got a bunch of clicks and then I joined
that to the users table which has their
phone number in it right and the way we
affect the outside world because the
only the only thing that exists inside
of our system are are tables and Views
the way we affect the outside world is
writing to a table so we have an SMS
outbox table and I'm going to basically
map that view at the top to the SMS
outbox table and so for every Row in the
first view I get a row in the SMS outbox
and for every one of those there's this
magical little thing sitting on the
outside of our world waiting for new
things to go into that table and when
they do it does something with them in
this case sends us a text
message and so that's sort of the way we
think about the outside
world we think of it as when you play
with you're playing inside of Eve you're
playing in this world where all we have
is data right there's no there's nothing
else going on you have data and
everything you want to do is Express
simply as a view over that
data but the truth is you can't we can't
live that way right we can't not have
drun drawing to the screen we can't not
have going to the network or any of
these things but the way we do it is
that that interface is still itself data
right if I want to affect the outside
world I stick a thing in a table if the
outside world wants to affect me if like
a web request comes back right then that
comes in as a tupal as data into the
system and so that means is that the
entire system is inherently reactive
right I never write code to talk about
sort of how things changed I just write
views over the the data that already
exists and they get updated as they go
or as new information comes to
light so we built that that version
where we were showing tables and we kept
trying to bootstrap and we kept ending
up in these like weird places where the
we needed to experiment more with the
platform and understand the semantics of
the language but the editor wasn't
really there to do it and trying to do
it all in tandem was kind of complicated
so we built this version that had a much
more
traditional albeit not very good syntax
as we found um where you wrote some
stuff in in a in a text editor and then
the sort of interesting bit was that we
showed you all the tables that you were
building to make this like uh
Association very clear so I'll show you
that one so this ended up being one of
the more interesting ones um because we
took it further than we had gone uh
before this one so uh we'll go through
the a short little tutorial
here um so in this syntax which again
don't get hung up on it's really bad um
but it works for us so in this syntax
you you declare a new view by putting a
star in front and you give it a name so
this is the user View and I I give it
some uh this is a way of sort of
inserting data directly in inside of
your code right I give it a a set of
headers and then I I just add rows and I
of course could add you know another row
in here you know Rob is 32 or whatever
you notice it's all live it's all
reactive which is probably unsurprising
coming from from me but
um we'll go on here and say things like
selecting the year born right and so we
get this means select from the user
table get the age column and born is you
know some simple calculation over that
thing and we get a little more
complicated we can do a join and if
you've ever done pro log or or data log
or any of these things we have sort of
this implicit join mechanism if a thing
has the same name then it's joined right
and so you can see here that uh user and
year born are joined on the age thing
because they both have age as their name
and so that gives me uh age born and
name and here was an example of like
aliasing that in case you have things
that you want to join that don't have
the same name obviously you need some
way of doing that and it makes the the
value over here nicer as
well let's go to something else so
filtering that's probably
unsurprising or uh yeah
filtering more complicated filtering
this is filtering on some
predicate and here's where it got
interesting so this is how you wrote an
aggregation and this is something for
what it's worth you know talking about
lessons we've learned turns out
aggregation is a really really really
hard problem um many of the versions of
Eve we have written have been because we
were trying to figure out how to make
aggregation work correctly uh and this
one had an interesting way of doing it
but maybe not the greatest way of doing
it um what this allowed you to do was
inside of one of your views you could
aggregate over another view and that did
not affect unlike SQL where you know you
say Group by and that affects your
actual query um in our case you could
aggregate inside of a query almost like
it were a sub select kind of thing going
on and that enabled us uh I'll show you
a little bit later that enabled us to
write remember that to-do MVC
application the one I showed you before
was about I think 140 lines um the the
to-do MVC we were able to write um in
this one had only 15 lines that were
devoted to logic at all everything else
was just rendering
stuff um so you can Aggregate and here's
how you draw things in this you if
you've ever seen hiccup enclosure or
sort of jsx is kind of this way to in
react land you create a sort of a data
structure and then you feed that to
something that turns that data structure
into HTML and you'll notice we got some
UI when I uncommented that
right so enough of this let's go look at
some funner some more interesting
things um so here's a clock written this
way uh this is all just drawing it and
me being terrible at math uh but I
mentioned before like when we want to
sort of interact with the outside world
the way we do it is by sticking
information in tables and so I wanted
want a timer so I created a little uh I
I basically said I want to stick into
the timer view this row uh and I gave it
some ID I have no idea why I chose three
but um and I wanted to when it when it's
going to tick I want it to give some
event and that event is tick and I want
to do it every a th000
milliseconds and so that means is now
there's a thing on the outside of the
system sticking tupal into our into our
world um once every second and that's
how the Clock Works and so all we end up
doing is going over the uh events table
that's what this guy is looking for the
label of tick because I said the event
was called tick and then I get the
maximum I get the latest is basically
all I'm trying to do and then I just
turn that into hours minutes and
seconds and so that's how you write
something like a clock this also extends
itself to uh let's see
here extends itself to doing recursive
things right uh so we can do graph
traversal here uh so you know I have a
bunch of edges from A to B B to C C to d
d to a and I state that there is a path
from uh for every Edge is from and to
and there is a another path where if
there's an edge from A to B and a path
from B to C then there is a path from a
to c right um and this extra thing here
is an unfortunate uh requirement of our
syntax where the names had to match up
in order for it to work out um so you
can kind of ignore that but this allowed
me to specify basically the parent
ancestor query that every prologue intro
has in it
right um and once you have recursion you
can of course write a during machine so
um you know we wanted to prove hey this
crazy language that that you know only
has views over time and basically works
over an immutable event log um Can in
fact do anything we need it to
do uh and the way this works is kind of
interesting so it represents the the
tape finitely even though technically
speaking it is infinite and we only sort
of like reify the portion of it we have
values
for um I can't remember exactly what
this one does I think it adds one and
two or something like
that a wonderful State machine uh and of
course the increment button which yeah
the screen really small that fits in a
tweet which is pretty cool you know
that's that's the measure of of good
right there I'm pretty sure what's
interesting though in this and the
reason why I'm showing it is this little
line here makes it so that this
increment or button event the set of
events related to this are now
shared so this made this program that
this line right here made this program
distributed right I mentioned before
that the that the original research here
is all about sort of building
distributed systems and so we get a lot
of very interesting benefits out of the
fact that essentially our language is
nothing more than a bunch of uh a bunch
of pure functions more or less over
tables
right um and so you know we implemented
chat programs and all that but I think
the interesting thing to show uh not
that
one this one is that once again this is
all
bootstrapped so the all those tables all
the like running UI all that stuff that
you saw was actually rendered by Eve
itself uh I turned off line numbers
because I wanted to conserve space but
this editor was written in 200
lines um the cool part about this is not
only is it drawing all of this but it is
actually uh it is actually pushing code
around to run your program in another
place so you know I'm I've got the
editor running right and it is also
running your your clock program or
whatever right and you can't have those
running in the same database at the same
time because their events would be sort
of messing with each other so what this
actually does is stick a bunch of of
facts inside of a remote code table and
tells it that hey we want you to go
execute this in some other place and so
it executes it in some other place and
that's what allows the clock here to
update without necessarily updating the
the uh editor here though you'll notice
it is updating and the way that's
working is it's actually subscribed to
that other threads database and it's you
know using pubsub
so this is a really cool really really
cool experiment we did all sorts of
crazy things with it um you know built
websites and did some like like basic
machine learning stuff and did important
things like you know do compound
interest which is interesting enough
requires you to do recursion which is
something most people don't
realize
um and so we we took this pretty far but
at the same time this is very programmer
right this is obviously just code U it's
an interesting take on the code and like
I said you can do some pretty impressive
things in a very small amount of it but
we we wanted to keep
exploring and at the time we were still
really stuck on this idea of I really
like the Excel thing can we can we find
the way to make the tables work out so
we tried it again and uh we showed this
Prototype at uh hacker school and this
is the first time we've had a version of
Eve that had a drag and drop UI
editor so in this I'm going to build the
incrementer button which might be a
little hard to see but I rightclick and
up Pops a menu it gives me a bunch of
options for things I can create I drag
out a little box it says button at the
top of it and I'm going to give my
button a name because names are good
right uh I call it incrementer and I
click the get clicks
button and if I make this view live and
click the button you'll notice for every
click I get a row inside of the clicks
table and as I mentioned before if you
wanted to
uh make the increment button all you
need to do is sort of count the number
of clicks inside of here and so what we
do is write an Excel formula we count
one of the things on the right on the
left hand
side in this case I counted event didn't
really matter which one and then all I
have to do is drag the column up to the
little bit of UI and ask me what I want
to bind it to in this case the only
thing I could bind it to was text and
Tada an increment button so this was
interesting for us for a number of
reasons um for one it was the first time
you could build a bit of UI without
writing any code you notice I mean the
only thing I did was write a single
formula in
there um you could do this in 30 seconds
which is also pretty cool you know from
start to finish you go to some website
you can drag a button out make it do
anything you want pretty
quickly but we found that this obscured
something very important
um which might not be a surprise to you
guys which is let's say I I put a bunch
of tables together and there are all
these joins going on and there's all
this filtering and all this stuff and
these these uh formulas and
whatnot none of that is is easily viewed
in this little view that I have here
right all you see is some headers and
and all that you lose all of the context
to understand what the view is actually
bringing in what its sources are what
it's actually doing
um and so we kind of went on an extreme
end of this uh so we decided okay we've
been doing this for a while now and
we've done lots of toy examples let's do
a real example let's completely clone
Four Square why we chose four squares
Beyond me because none of us actually
had ever used it um but we did and um we
sort of along the way had to build a
version of Eve that was capable of doing
something that complicated right uh and
we we still were interested in like
exploring well can we fix that problem
of context and the table thing and can
we make a more a much more powerful UI
editor and so I'll show you a little bit
of of what using this guy looked
like let's
see okay so uh you know I have my
workspace over here I have a set of
tables and Views and all sorts of fun
things over here and you can see I have
a list of my favorite books which is not
unfortunately very
long um and let's say I wanted to build
a little list view of these so that I
can see the the name of the book and the
ratings of
them and so what I'm going to do
is uh build create a new little UI page
here and one of the things we we were
interested in doing was
replicating a UI editor that could
actually realistically build something
like four square right one of the
problems with wizzywig tools is they
don't tend to scale up very well to
deeply sort of nested or or uh sort of
very complex sites and so we took a page
out of the way designers actually use
Photoshop to design these very complex
websites and we gave ourselves um layers
basically we called them
groups and so if I wanted to you know
create a little box on here and I want
to I want to have one of these for every
one of my books right
um you know it's this nice wizzy wig
thing I can sit here and change the
color of my lovely little box and add
some
uh some border radius and I can stick
some text into here we'll put the title
into this
guy and change some colors make it look
nice right center it great and I can
preview it and surpr it doesn't look any
different because we haven't made it you
know actually bound to anything yet but
if we want to bind it all we have to do
is take our favorite books drag it onto
here um just close this guy Up Click
preview and you'll notice hey I have
four things that say title that's cool
because I have four books in my thing
and I can just say well I want the name
there and now I have the name and we can
make our text a little bit bigger so
that it's not doing that not that
bad that's pretty cool and we can stick
a spacer in
here oops a spacer resize it now they
have space in between them right so this
is basically what you could imagine is
almost like if you took angular and then
built a wizzywig editor for data binding
on top of it right uh and surprisingly
enough this is all you need to then
build something as complicated as a
production ready for
square um
as another example I mentioned uh we can
build the incrementer I guess uh let's
see
so create a new
page grab this and I'll do the
incrementer because it'll show you what
queries look like and I will warn you
it's
horrendous um this was not one of our
better
ideas uh so put a button ey down
here and we can say you know click me
exclamation point make it big Center
it pretty
colors like that that's the prettiest of
colors right and so yay we have a button
and if I click on it we'll go and we'll
see the clicks table has Clicks in it
again so I'm going to create a
view and we want to count something so
I'm going to click this count blob here
and you'll see I get get this crazy
looking thing at the top don't worry
about that too much but what I want to
do is I want to tell it I'm going to
drag the clicks onto here so I'm
counting the clicks and I have to tell
it well what are you counting exactly
well I'll count the event number I guess
and then if I drag whoops if I drag the
result out tells me I have three
excellent uh I have to do this don't ask
me why it's a bad
idea all right we'll name it and we'll
go down here and go back to incrementer
and unfortunately you're going to see a
bug in here that I was not able to
figure out why it's happening now it
didn't used to but for some reason it
now duplicates my
button um but if I do that you can see
okay now I have the increment button
again and again it's sort of an
interesting way of working with this
world right all I have are these tables
of data and I'm writing views over top
of
them so yeah so we built four square
with that that was
fun and we didn't like it that the way
of working with the queries I didn't
show you any more complicated ones
because they would be just completely
unintelligible um was really hard and so
we started exploring well how do we
actually make it better the table thing
didn't seem to be working very well uh
and one of the things we realized is
that when we tried to explain queries to
each other we constantly did it by
drawing
diagrams um that looked like entity
relationship
diagrams and so we're like hey well what
if we tried that what if we just tried
you know representing all queries as
entity relationship diagrams or you know
some approximation thereof and so we
built what we ultimately release we're
all open source now this is e version
zero in this
screenshot um and you can see this is
the famous triangle query right or the
three-click query it's a pretty hard
query to optimize for in databases um
and you'll notice that it is just a
triangle which is wonderful right we
have this very nice natural mapping to
I'm looking for a shape inside of the
database which is sort of the intuition
we had is that anytime you're querying
for a thing what you're really looking
for is a
shape um and so you know you have this
this nice triangle of friends thing you
can see I can get sort of intermediate
information about what's going on I
click on one of the friends relations
and I can see that table directly in
line so there's like this peaking
mechanism and all that good stuff and
results are down at the bottom now
here's another more complicated query so
this is this is one that has a bunch of
aggregations in it so it's like well
let's calculate uh the percent of the
total salary per every Department inside
of a system so this is something that
would be very hard to do in Excel um and
the sequel for this is pretty awful
actually um so we we did a comparison we
sat a bunch of people down and like
here's the sequel here's a picture and
explain both to me right um and there's
no statistical validity in that but it
worked out pretty well and it was like
the first time we had actually seen
people really understand a thing just by
looking at it and a and a couple minute
explanation of from us of what it was
that they were looking
at so we did this and we built some
built some things with it but we weren't
really happy there this is a very nice
way of sort of viewing a thing but it's
not necessarily the nicest way of
building a thing uh we actually did some
work and made it very
efficient made it made it very efficient
but uh we wanted to try something else
and so I'm going to show you one of our
latest
experiments uh if you followed my
Twitter at all you will have seen me
posting things about doing Mad Libs
again um and so I will show you an
editor that is a slightly different take
on Mad Libs and actually this will look
rather similar to Williams stuff um in a
way so you know let's say I'm going to
do that friends thing again right and if
I put a question mark it means I have
some blank blank inside of here I don't
know what it is and I can submit that
and you can see it actually renders it
as some blanks right as blank is friends
with blank and now I can add some some
data to that so I can say Chris is
friends with Rob and Rob is
friends with Chris and Rob is
friends with
Joe and if I submit those you can see
everything updates so this is a little
bit like that Mathematica style notebook
thing going on again and I can scrub
through these and see all my my lovely
facts about the
world um and as with all the other ones
we can do some interesting things in
here so we can say well
whoops uh we can say you know who is
Chris friends with you can see well we
have one match it's Rob right or we can
say who uh who is Rob's friend Rob
friends with and we can join The Way We
join is something like
this we can literally just link these
together right so this is a kind of an
interesting way of looking at the
world um and amazingly enough you can
build all sorts of really neat things
this way um so if we wanted to uh we can
gather all the people that a person is
friends with so you can see Rob is
friends with both Chris and Joe so I'm
getting the set now instead of just uh
each row
individually and we can change this we
can count them
again drag and drop so now we have the
counts that's pretty cool the way you
think about change inside of the system
is now I can add a new fact as a result
of that for example blank has blank
friends again drag and drop Chris you
know has or Rob has two friends in this
case we can
see
that and of course since the last last
time I showed being able to then chart
this I am going to make a chart of all
of
these it's a very interesting chart of
course right so this is just again a
very different take and I'm not saying
that anything we've done is the right
idea or any of it is necessarily a good
idea but what I will say is that um we
have to start exploring this space more
you know I know Jonathan is a big
proponent of turning sort of this event
right into a Congregation of the people
who are starting to think about these
things um and we have to explore we have
to experiment we have to question our
assumptions in every way we possibly can
literally the past year and a half's
worth of work for us we've thrown it
away right we do it and we do it over
and over again to learn more to
understand more to test it to see what
we can discover um and I hope more of
you guys will will do that too so thank
you
[Applause]